おぅぇ..
はい、こちら。
ちょっと前に僕がつくった巨大スーパーボールがあるんですけども。
まあ、おかげさまで上手くいきました。
ありがとうございます。
一応スーパーボール自体は上手くいったんですけども、
この巨大スーパーボールの素材となっている「おゆまる」って粘土があるんだけども、
その粘土がね～説明によるとちゃんと書いてあったよ。
僕はちゃんと確認しましたからね。
シュンシュン（指を動かす音）
80度以上のお湯につけて3,4分程こう浸すと形が変わるっていう
たくさんの「おゆまる」を買って温めて合体させて作ったのがコレなんですけども。
まぁ、これだけで終わるのはもったいないと思ったんで僕ちょっと試したんすよ。
コレをまるごとね100度位のお湯にズボッて入れてね。こう、ずっと煮込んだりしたんですけども
変化がなかった。
まったく変化がなかった。
ホントにね硬いんすよ。もう無理。
もうお前は「おゆまる」じゃなくなったよ。
お前は「おゆまる」の役目を終えた。
お前の人生は今日から「スーパーボール」
おゆまる「僕はおゆまるじゃないの？」
はじめ「いやっ、お前はもうおゆまるじゃねえ。スーパーボールだ。」
おゆまる「えっ！そんなのイヤだあ～！」
はじめ「すまねえ。俺にはどうすることもできねえんだ。」
おゆまる「やだやだやだやだやだ・・やだやだやだ・・やだやだやだやだ・・やだやだ～やだやだ～やだぁ！」
ドンッ！！
分かった。俺はなあお前の人生をスーパーボールだけで終わらせたくないんだよ。だから俺は..決めた
僕にはちゃんと今日秘策があるので。
その秘策で今日はお前「スーパーボール」お前を今日はおゆまるに戻してやる。
多分いけると思うんだけどもちょっとわかんないです。確証は持てない。
けど俺は自分の全力を尽くしてみるよ。
では、いこう。
まっ、動画のサムネイルとタイトル見れば分かると思うんだけども～
炊飯器を使おうと思います。
要するにおゆまるがどうやって戻れればいいかってことを考えたときに
まあ、間違いなく熱なんすよ。
熱を与えればこの形が戻る。柔らかくなる。
熱を与える方法たくさんあると思いました。
例えばなんですえども、電子レンジ・ドライヤー・アイロン・直火で炙る
まあ色々あったんだけどもなんかこう一番ねコンスタントにかつ永続的に攻撃をあたえられる作戦の一つとしてはとしては
やっぱりこの「炊飯器」
炊飯器が一番こうなんか地道にダメージをあたえれるんじゃないかと思いました。
爆発したらどうしよう・・・・・。
白米だな。お前は白米だ。
白米としてちょっと実際に巨大スーパーボールを炊飯器でたいみようと思います。
いくわよお～～！！（オネェ口調）
ファイヤッッ！！
うわこれどうなんだろうな～
まってるからな、おゆまる。
これだけでかい粘土だったら色んなことできると思うんすよ。
ガコッ（閉まらない音）
えっ？
スーッ
ガコッ（閉まらない音）
ヤベッ
ヤベッそういうことか。
そういうことか～
やばいな～ちょっとお前大きいなあ。
ちょっと物理的に小さくしてみます。
ズチズチズチッ（つぶす音）
どうだあ～
ガコッ（閉まらない音）
変化ねえわ
どっどうしようどっどうしよどうしよどうしよ。まじでどうしよう。
１かい切ろうとしたんですけど硬すぎて無理だったんすよねえ。
フライパンであぶるか。
でもね~なんか俺の予想だとこのままやっててもなんないんすよ。
ダメだったんすよ。
重さをかければ縮むと思うんだけど。
ちょびっとでいいからさホントに。
あぁ～～～どうなんだろ。ちょっと縮んだ気はするけど
ではちょっと炊飯器入れてみます。
そう結局底しかねこんななんないんすよ。
まて指熱い
アッッツッッ！！！
どうだ？入りそう？
あとは高さの問題。
ガンッ（閉まらない音）
もうちょい！
いけそう。
アアッ
フイッ（ふり向く音）
待って。おいおいおいおい開かなくなちゃったよ
多分今ぎゅうぎゅう詰めすぎて開かなくなってるだけだから。
♪～炊くときの音楽（炊飯器）
パンパンッ
後は任せた
ではちょっとスーパーボール炊くのを待っててください。
♪～
♪～炊けた音楽（炊飯器）
おおっ
キラリンッ
あるべき姿にもどっているのでしょうか？
スリー・トゥー・ワン
オープン！ガコッ（開く音）
カチッ（閉める音）
頼むぞ
ちょっと溶けたあ・・？
さっきまでさギリギリだったのに結構小さくなってるし、周りも結構溶けてます。
エエッ！結構コレきたんじゃない？きたんじゃない？（声高めw）
ガコッ（開ける音）
おおおっ！！
まってこれさ、もう何回かかやったらいけるんじゃない？
かなり縮みましたよ。
ちょっともういっかい！
あと10回くらい再加熱してもう多分いけてるんじゃないかと思います。
おゆまる・・本来の姿に戻ってくれ・・・
オープン！
おっ！もうもうもう
アアッーーーーーー！！
もう間違いなくスーパーボールではなくなってる。
やったじゃん、お前
お前
あっつ！！！ま、まじあっつ！！あっつっ！！
おお！おお！おお！きた！きたきたきたきたっ！きたっ！
やったー！！とれた！！
やったあ～～！！スーパーボールじゃなくなったよ！！
やった！ドシドシッ（つぶす音）